bienvenidos a en 5 minutos donde
intentamos explicar de manera sencilla
asuntos complicados según la onu la
guerra en ucrania podría afectar a
millones de personas llevándolas
potencialmente a la pobreza a la
indigencia o al hambre cómo afecta este
conflicto a la seguridad alimentaria
cuáles son los países más afectados y
qué soluciones hay para evitar este tipo
de crisis rusia y ucrania son conocidos
como los graneros de europa estos dos
países exportan cerca del 30 por ciento
del trigo que el mundo consume el 17 por
ciento del maíz el 32 por ciento de la
cebada y el 75 por ciento del aceite de
girasol según datos de la onu lucia
también es el principal exportador
mundial de gas natural y el segundo de
petróleo indispensables para producir y
transportar alimentos el trigo que
producen estos países es fuente de
alimento esencial para muchas de las
personas más pobres del mundo y es que
aparte de ser los mayores productores
son los que venden estos productos más
baratos áfrica importa la mitad de su
trigo de estos dos países y en 2021
ucrania la mayor fuente individual para
el programa mundial de alimentos pero
tras el inicio de la guerra rusia no ha
podido exportar gran parte de sus
alimentos debido a las sanciones
impuestas por occidente y en ucrania la
agricultura se ha derrumbado y sus
exportaciones han quedado bloqueadas por
los ataques a sus puertos en el mar
negro y el mar de azov desde principios
del 2022 los precios del maíz y del
trigo han aumentado en un 30% los del
petróleo en más del 60% en el último año
mientras que los del gas natural y los
fertilizantes se han duplicado los 45
países menos desarrollados del mundo
importan al menos un tercio de su trigo
de ucrania o rusia de estos 18 países
importan más del 50% entre estos figuran
egipto república democrática del congo
libia somalia sudán y yemen y la
situación para líbano en una crisis
económica severa es crítica ya que este
país importa de ucrania y rusia el 75
por ciento de su trigo pero hay otro
aspecto fundamental en esta crisis los
fertilizantes gran parte de estos
insumos está atrapada en rusia y belarús
su aliado tras las sanciones impuestas
por la guerra rusia y belarús producen
grandes cantidades de potasa y fosfato
básicos para producir fertilizantes que
son usados a nivel mundial para
incentivar el crecimiento de cultivos de
todo tipo de vegetales cosechas que
alimentan tanto a humanos como a ganado
muchos agricultores fomentan con
fertilizantes sus cultivos de soja o
pastos con los que dan a comer al ganado
sin estos insumos los pasos son más
pequeños y por lo tanto las vacas los
cerdos o los pollos serán también
menores y producirán menos carne y leche
y si esto significa también más escasez
de sus productos a todo ello se suma la
especulación los comerciantes y los
productores suben los precios de sus
productos ya que saben que muchos
pagarán más para conseguirlos la escasez
de fertilizantes afecta de manera
crítica a países como china o moldavia
en américa latina' si bien la región no
es tan dependiente de los alimentos de
otros países si lo es de los
fertilizantes rusos y bien los rusos
brasil gigante de la agricultura en la
región importa cerca del 20% de sus
fertilizantes otros países afectados son
honduras perú ecuador panamá costa rica
méxico o colombia el resultado es que se
están disparando los precios de los
alimentos en todo el mundo todo ello en
un momento en que el cambio climático
afecta a las cosechas en muchos
territorios las economías apenas
comienzan a recuperarse de los efectos
de la pandemia y los países enfrentan
una inflación vertiginosa esto se
acentúa en países pobres que además
arrastran deudas históricas que salidas
hay para la crisis a corto plazo
naciones unidas llama a una cooperación
global pide evitar el acaparamiento de
insumos y poner las reservas a
disposición de los países con menos
recursos y a los organismos financieros
liberar fondos para ayudarlos pero a
largo plazo los expertos hacen un
llamado de atención y piden ver la
crisis en ucrania como una evidencia de
que el modelo de producción de alimentos
actuales es un peligro para la vida de
millones de personas puesto que depende
de cadenas de suministro e intereses
internacionales así como del transporte
con combustibles fósiles por ello instan
a los gobiernos a fomentar la
agricultura local como financiando y
dando más poder a los pequeños
agricultores y a los mercados nacionales
para hacerlos menos dependientes piden
también fomentar los insumos orgánicos
ya que aparte de ser más económicos que
los fertilizantes químicos ayudan a
luchar contra el cambio climático si les
sirvió el vídeo para entender las
implicaciones de la guerra en ucrania en
la seguridad alimentaria nos esperamos
en otro episodio de en cinco minutos en
france 24 y france24 puntocom